Yvonne is an Iowa City Iowa hi Yvonne hi
Dave so what is your net worth we're
about 1.4 we have about 450,000
retirements and then we have a $300,000
home and about a $350,000 auto body shop
and then an $85,000 rental home and then
miscellaneous cash and stuff so 1.4
gotcha and and how old are you guys
we are 48 okay my husband a knife how
much of this money did you inherit not a
dime okay
and what is your average income
household so you're working last time I
looked at last ten years has been about
126 probably before that when we were in
our 20s and 30s probably around probably
90,000 back then what was your career
track well I I am an accountant him and
I were high school sweethearts so I'm an
accountant his dad had a body shop and
so I had done the books and Tony worked
for his dad and then we bought the shop
and some weep on the shop since 92 so
you have a four-year degree in
accounting yes what about him he never
went to college
nope what was your GPA it was a 3.8 but
I was definitely not a natural person I
had to really work I was not bright like
a couple of colors ago I had to work
really hard that's what's the most
expensive pair of jeans you guys have
ever bought never more or less probably
$40 at that I don't even wear jeans I
wear khakis and my husband oh it's his
jeans from the local farm supply store
okay so he's in the auto body business
so I know the answer to this but how
many new cars did you buy before you had
a million dollars none we've told Kelly
my first car was a Pinto Sharon's two
and I've owned three Jags so but
actually probably more in our 20s and
30s where we're warmer I was more
materialistic not that way really
anymore
I'm he's driving around
2008 Thailand country I'm driving around
2006 solder and just the bebop around I
love it
Yvonne thank you for sharing your story
you guys are great American success
stories well there you have it folks
aircraft mechanic produce manager
electrical engineer insurance sales body
shop a factory worker and a teacher
there's your millionaires wow that's
insightful this is the Dave Ramsey show
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others